with the black lightning DC launched his
first television show starring a black
superhero it's a milestone that's been a
long time coming but it's not the first
time Jefferson Pierce has managed to
break a long-standing barrier since
first appearing over 40 years ago he
served as a member of the Justice League
the outsiders a solo superhero and even
provided the DC Universe with a legacy
of heroic characters from his origins on
the page all the way to his current
status on the screen
he is the fascinating truth behind Black
Lightning DC's first black superhero the
first three decades of the superhero
genre were overwhelmingly White's but in
the late 60s that began to change at
Marvel Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
introduced a black panther and in 1973
Hero for Hire issue number one made Luke
Cage the first black superhero to
headline his own book at DC however
things moved a little more slowly
it wasn't until 1977 that Tony Isabella
a writer who had previously worked on
luke cage's adventures was hired to
create their first headlining black
superhero with isabella and artist
trevor von eden that year saw the debut
of black lightning Jefferson Pierce was
a gold medal winning Olympic decathlete
had returned to his old neighborhood in
Metropolis to work as a teacher when one
of his students was killed in an
altercation with a criminal organization
called the 100 Pierce decided to hit the
streets with a hi-tech costume to take
them on himself the black bomber the
hero that almost was Paul Platt
lightning was the idea that made it to
the page he wasn't DC's first thoughts
when it came to creating a black
superhero and as Isabella revealed on
his blog the original plan might have
been the worst idea in comics history
when Isabella was hired the editors
pitched him a character called the black
bomber with a hook being that he was
actually a white racist who turned into
a super-powered black man when he was
stressed out but neither personality
being aware of the other in other words
DC's first black superhero was not
actually going to be black and would
feature plenty of stereotypes including
a basketball uniform costume
fortunately for everyone concerned
Isabella taught them out of air 30 years
later though writer Dwayne McDuffie
well known for making satirical jabs at
the superhero genre worked him into a
story about an alternate reality where
everything had gone so wrong that the
brown bomber could be on the Justice
League The Outsiders the original run of
black lightning was canceled
after only 11 issues but if it's any
consolation it wasn't alone instead it
was a casualty of what fans have dubbed
the DC implosion all told a DC gave the
axe to twenty titles it was a move that
came so suddenly that most of those
series even had completely finished
stories including black lightning issue
12 that stayed in DC's archives until
they were published in a book called
cancelled comic cavalcade to secure the
copyrights five years later Black
Lightning got a second chance at stardom
when Batman quit the Justice League over
that teens reluctance to cause an
international incident he put together a
new team called The Outsiders the roster
included a handful of new characters
like katana who would go on to appear in
the Suicide Squad movie but it also
revived a few existing heroes including
Black Lightning over the course of the
outsiders five-year run everyone on the
team got a spotlight story highlighting
their mysterious handle tortured past
and Black Lightning was no exception in
his case it given up his costumed
identity and powers due to guilt over
the accidental death of a bystander
named - Trina Shelton whose family would
eventually return to get revenge I'm the
one who taught him to fly Black
Lightning had lighting his own show as a
new development but kress Williams isn't
actually the first actor to play the
character in live-action that honor
Believe It or Not goes to stand-up
comedian simbad who took a brief turn as
black lightning on a 1992 episode of
Saturday Night Live in a sketch set to
Superman's funeral tying into the van
current Death of Superman storyline cast
members like Chris Farley Dana Carvey
and Chris Rock appeared as Superman's
fellow heroes however Black Lightning
wasn't invited leading to an altercation
with Jimmy Olsen and by the way SNL
effects department that's not what
lightning looks like it's not the most
flattering portrayal for sure and the
part where Batman doesn't recognize his
old teammate is a real heartbreaker but
it is an interesting bit of pop-culture
prominence for a character who was still
pretty obscure for mainstream audiences
thunder lightning and grace with black
lightnings ties to the original roster
of the outsiders it's not surprising
that it have a connection to the team
when a new version was put together in
2003 in Outsiders issue 1 Judd Winick
and Tom Rainey introduced an disappears
aka Thunder the oldest of black
lightnings two daughters like her father
Anissa added some much-needed diversity
to the DC Universe when it
revealed that she was in a romantic
relationship with another member of the
outsiders crates joy her powers however
are completely different she can control
her density making her nearly
invulnerable in 2008 a nYSSA's younger
sister Jennifer originally introduced as
part of another alternate reality in the
pages of Kingdom Come joined her in the
mainstream continuity with powers that
was similar to her father's she took the
name lightning joining the Justice
League in 1979 the Black Lightning was
offered membership in the JLA but turned
it down becoming only the second
character ever to do so 30 years later
he finally accepted in 2006 Batman
Superman and Wonder Woman spent a story
arc literally sitting around the table
with a bunch of trading card style
photographs of their fellow heroes
debating who they should let into a
reformed League around that same time a
swamp zombie rebuilt a killer robot so
he could turn Red Tornado human and then
tear off his arm and ether yeah
that really happened but anyway that was
a MacGuffin to get plot lightning and
the rest to join up the Justice League
decided to just keep everyone who showed
up to fight the latest crisis and he
stuck around for the next few years
after DC we booted their universe in
2011 and then rebirthed it in 2016
he was south of the league and back to
being a solo hero the CW's Black
Lightning with the new Black Lightning
TV show The CW is pulling from the
entire history of the character in some
pretty interesting ways kress Williams
stars as Jefferson Pierce who still
works in education and his TV
incarnation he's the principal of a high
school in the city of Freeland who has
dedicated his tenure to helping kids and
eliminating violence like his earliest
Comics incarnation the CW's Black
Lightning is taking on the hundred and
Tobias whale and getting his costume and
equipment from Peter Gumby like the
version that showed up in Batman on the
outsiders he's been retired from super
heroics driven to give up on being a
vigilante by his aversion to violence
Anissa and Jennifer have already
appeared on the show both with the
powers they have in the comics and great
joy as arrows and hisses love interest
the only thing that could really
complete the saga is if they manage to
get an appearance by simbad thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]